e
e e
mus for all right let's get
started are you ready
careful all right thank you so I
understand that the comproller would
like to go first
yes is that right so yes that would be
great all right so we'll move her to to
the next item of business and otherwise
approve the
agenda any other agenda changes no uh
all those in favor I any oppos okay good
go
ahead okay um my sections are sort of I
uh I guess number four and number five
on your agenda so you have the um the
book that we issued last November in
front of you the big green book
um what when the agencies present to you
through these uh fiveyear reviews
they'll we've tried to align their
presentations with the book so you can
kind of watch you know read their
presentation along with the book um so
hopefully that will make things smooth
the normal report that I give you every
year on the inactive funds um Jen just
passed around to you um we just kind of
take a snapshot of anything that appears
inactive based on activity in our
financial system for the last two years
some of these are are repeats every year
and you've talked to them before um a
couple of them may look new but
sometimes um new funds get established
and they take some time to get started
to actually get Revenue in especially if
it's something that's donation based um
they're not going to have revenue on day
one so sometimes it does take a couple
of years even to get these things
started um and sometimes the spending
Trails behind as well so you'll see if
if any of these um spark your interest I
can get you more information directly
from the agencies uh the top section are
agencies that are not coming to see you
this year so if you want some questions
answered or you do want them to come in
they they're not planning to be here but
we can certainly reach out and get you
some more
information uh the the second section
are the folks that are reporting to you
this year so um Department of Natural
and cultural resources is on your
Wednesday agenda and education is here
today so they can speak to you directly
about the funds that they have that are
considered inactive and then on the last
page uh a flip the page is just
Transportation who you spoke with last
year um they do have a couple of funds
that popped up on the new sort of newly
inactive list but they have some that
you are you definitely had on your list
as inactive last year as well so they
you know they would be ones that you can
decide if you want to speak with them at
all so could you make us a revised
version of this table that has the
amount that's currently in these funds
um well it just means there's no
activity so there might the amount may
be zero um in some cases the amount may
be stagnant but it typically
um the fact I I can do that for you um
but in a lot of
cases it's that there's no ins and outs
in the last two years so part of this
review that's my point is but if it's 3
million dollar with no ins and outs then
we might want to investigate it but if
it's 50 cents sure we can I can add the
balance uh sometimes yeah I I guess it
depends on each fund but um most of them
are typically relatively low balances
thank you
um that's the only handout I had yeah
for
today and I'm sorry I didn't introduce
myself I'm Dana
call most of you saw me last year but
right um did we do we have a secretary
in my
head thank you I didn't bring paper um
and um can we assume that
anything
after 3 316 or 344 I'm not sure which is
new enough that they can't reasonably
have started
operations yes I'll the last four on
those are relatively new cuz if if
they're numbered in the high 3es then
they have been recently ad Ed in the
last couple years and likely just
haven't had any funding yet so that is a
good
assumption other questions for Miss call
Rep Senator gray not necessarily
question what I generally do is youve
got the the RSA numbers here and the
book has an index by the RSA number so
you just look up the RSA number go back
in front number and you can be right
there at the P so it's it's not tough to
do get that balance and I book what the
book since it's inactive fun that what's
in the book ought to be pretty darn
close to what they've got
now right even the new ones we give them
a page in the book even if it's all
zeros they get a page so that you get a
description of the fund you know when it
was created that type of information but
it could stay it could stay um with no
numbers for four years some of them do
so but I can put that I can add that
column to the memo that's not hard all
right thank you other comments yes
representative I got one more question
on is the judicial Council still in this
in this book I believe their one uh last
fund was repealed so yeah they wouldn't
uh depending on the timing of the repeal
sometimes it lags and they stay in the
book if they were repealed during the
course of the fiscal year but I can
check I know we had them not come to
their review with you because their one
fund was repealed so
right and we've got to figure out if
it's in the
statute it it should have been repealed
both from 612 and the underlying statute
typically that we try to make sure that
happens
but I'll double
check and I'll be here I'm just I'm
staying as long as I can but I have a
commitment later this afternoon so I'll
listen in and help with any questions
all right thank you Miss call anything
else all right next item on the agenda
is uh status of legislation so we had
our bill last year House
Bill we had our bill last year House
Bill 16
the left does nothing the right one goes
on and
off that's weird I only have one so I
have a different
model oh this is the
chance oh well all it doesn't matter all
right so um so our bill passed that was
signed by the governor it had one small
addition from what we sent into it which
was um that the uh veterinarians were
only getting 80% of the cost of of their
fees for neutering and um so the bill
changed it to 100% right so that that
was the only only small change but other
than that it was the same bill we had
come up
with okay um fiscal year uh compilation
of dedicated funds okay we already did
that big big book and active funds all
right agency review is the banking
Department
here thank
you and let's let's find their page
here and you've also
got spreadsheet now for each of these oh
okay and it does give the
six2 but we really should start putting
the page number about
yeah just bear with us for a moment sure
if you could tell me the page number two
I've not seen it's 257
27 yes because they are not
obviously
the numbers yeah they're in some weird
number all right so I see you have one
dedicated fun we do so please introduce
yourself sure good afternoon my name is
Amelia Galder I'm the bank commissioner
for the State of New Hampshire um we do
have as you can see oh
yes
galeri g a l d is in dog i e r
i
sure my name is hopeless to spell
so yeah
don't even get started on my first name
I'll answer to anything really that
sounds like
Amelia it's not no my parents it's my
parents and my husband none of this is
my fault um it's em
l e m l all right thank you continue
okay um so yes as you can see from the
report uh the banking department does
have one dedicated fund um and we are
uh we use the dedicated fund that we
have heavily and it's key to the
function of the banking department so we
would like to keep it active please um
as you may or may not be aware the
banking department is a self-funded
agency um that means in short every year
we get an appropriation from the
legislature and then over the course of
the fiscal year we collect fees and
fines um and if necessary an assessment
at the end of the fiscal year to fully
refund that appropriation and all those
fees find and if necessary an assessment
go into the dedicated fund with the sole
purpose to pay that um pay that uh
appropriation back at the end of the
fiscal year um so for that reason we
need a dedicated fund it's how our whole
agency is set up um we revolve around
the dedicated
fund I'm happy to answer any questions
was there an unusually big um fine in
2022 there was there was so we did like
I think it was Clos to $2 million so
we've been we actually that enabled us
to lower our per DM assessment on the
entities that we regulate so our fees
actually correspondingly got lowered
because of that large fine gotcha other
questions from the
committee representative
Aly how
much how much do you expect to keep in
there um for emergency kinds of things
from year to year yeah so I mean ideally
so my goal is always to avoid an
assessment because if we don't have
enough to pay back at to pay back the
appropriation we do an assessment and an
assessment on the consumer credit side
is very administratively burdensome we
have about 4,000 entities that are
licensed under us so we'd have to like
calculate out each portion of theirs so
um my goal is to always retain some in
this dedicated fund so that way we never
get to the point where we have to do an
assessment but the goal is to keep keep
it as low as we can and feasibly do
that so your expenses are very
predictable but the revenue is not is
that right or not well it depends on the
fine so some years we have a big fine um
because we catch somebody doing
something unlawful um and then the FI
the revenues go up and then we calculate
out our per DM rate that we charge for
the examiner the exam time and we take
into account that we took in a large
fine so we can reduce that expense so
it's but our most of our budget is
salaries and benefits so in terms of our
actual budget it is relatively
predictable because I think we're at
like 82% or 86% of our budget is
salaries and benefits right and and but
there's also fees which are probably
pretty predictable too right yeah yep to
some extent yes uh our licensing fees
have been the same for a long time
however um the economy somewhat dictates
how many lenses we have at any any given
moment if there's a lot of um if for
example mortgage rates are high right
now so there's
not a lot of people gain new licenses to
be mortgage Originators for example so
that tends to bring our licensing fees
down in that department or that division
a little bit um so it is a little bit
subject to
fluctuation thank
you other questions yes yeah
representative W what's a typical Bank
pay for this
service
so uh so for an examination are you
asking how much we charge on average for
an examination of a bank okay so um on
average a bank exam takes give or take
60 days so our per DM right now for
banks is a little over
$1,000 so about $60,000 give or
take depending it you know it sort of
depends on the business model of the
bank
um what what they're up to how many
examiners we have to staff if anything's
going
on
yep how often does a bank get uh
examined every 18 months give or take
some get examined more frequently if
they've got certain things going on um
if they're a denovo bank a brand new
bank they get examined every year and we
also do a visitation on a denovo bank
great all right other questions no
representative Al
com I'm I'm sorry I can't I I apologize
um I'm going DEA too uh could um I
couldn't understand how how you were
having trouble with just fees in
figuring out um and then you mentioned
settlements later but it'd be good if
you didn't include fines in the funding
source because it seems to be quite
significant okay I guess it's not broken
out here we do like when we report to
and this is a little bit beyond me
because I don't actually do the
reporting in New Hampshire first and all
of that but we do have a separate bucket
as we call it for fines and a different
bucket for exam fees so we do have that
data out there yeah um and it all goes
into the same one yeah I'm sure this is
just a very generalized report
all
right seeing no more questions thank you
very much thank you very
much
um all
right the uh next is the Veterans
Home and the Veterans Home is on
page it's on page I'll try to put them
all with 174 later 17
all
right thank you for coming please
introduce yourself hello my name is Kim
McKay I'm the commant of the New
Hampshire veterans
home um Paul Lloyd I'm the chairman of
the board of
managers Kim McConnell McKay I think
McKay yes and c k a y
on director of the uh commant commant I
know quite a quite a title isn't
it it it fits uh and Paul Lloyd Paul
Lloyd chairman of the board of
managers huh never heard of them before
thank
you um so I guess we'll just start with
um page
174 we provided you a handout that has a
little bit of History if someone's not
familiar with the New Hampshire veterans
home and how it's managed um so it it
was established in
1890 134 years we are um made up of uh
the board of managers who oversees the
actual um managing of the facility with
the governor we have uh 12 members that
sit on that board um all citizens two of
those are actual veterans that live at
our facility so they oversee the
operations of the veterans home we are
intermediate long-term care facility uh
we have licensed for 250 beds in the
state of New Hampshire we are budgeted
usually for 2 25 and we have nearly 400
uh staff with the state um our greatest
challenge right now is
Recruitment and we are uh state-owned
but the majority of our funding does
come from the VA Grant Program for those
veterans who reside with us our mission
statement is uh to provide the best
quality of life for New Hampshire
veterans with dignity honor and respect
which we work every day at uh there is a
form in here called the resident data
dashboard that is similar to this um it
has the breakdown of what we have for
veterans right now we have 129 veterans
117 of them are men 12 are women um and
we always have the ongoing discussion
about what branch is the best branch so
we break that down because our residents
love to be competitive um and then we
have the uh conflict air uh era in our
application weit list and our weit list
for beds so I just wanted to give you
some general information again our
primary source of Revenue is through the
VA about 39% of our budget comes through
the VA uh for the pum rate uh room and
board that's 32% where veterans pay for
their room and board if they have the uh
means and the assets to do so and then
General funds covers about 29% of the
cost we have three dedicated funds
the benefit account the guide Thompson
Memorial trust and the members
account the yes let me let me ask a
quick question is this uh money from the
Veterans Affairs is that new no that's
the way it's always been paid they it's
a PDM rate we um we have two levels of
uh care for our resident uh if they are
70% or more disabled then they are
called a prevailing rate resident if
they are under 69% or less they are
called a basic rate and uh the pum rate
is a daily at midnight we do a count of
how many residents we have and then the
VA pays that portion uh to care for
them because I was on division three
years ago and and it seemed to me that
the Veterans Home was 100% state but I
guess I'm not not not as far back that's
the way I remembered it but okay I'm
wrong yes that's okay it's good right
it's a good thing to have the VA cover
our cost um so three dedicated funds uh
as I said the benefit account is our
largest account that account um is funds
all of our uh quality of life activities
the monies that go into that benefit
fund are through donations so D
donations from our veteran service
organizations from Community um people
who want to donate to the veterans home
memorials and that is all uh in one
account and um as you can see that those
are things that we use out of that
account are voted by the board of
managers um and we look at that so an
example is cable for all residents the
state of New Hampshire doesn't pay for
that the benefit fund pays for that um
different outings that they go on so the
first two accounts are very similar in
the sense that the goal is to cover
those those um activities the second uh
dedicated account and I can go in more
detail uh is the guy Thompson Memorial
account and that is a $155,000 base
account uh that we never touch the
principal so we only take uh the
interest from that and we honestly take
that around Christmas time we withdraw
that around Christmas time to help pay
for Christmas for the veterans um all of
these funds these dedicated funds uh
these two accounts are managed or all of
our accounts are managed by the New
Hampshire treasury as well for
investment purposes so the dedicated
fund the largest one is the benefit fund
the majority of that those funds are
invested um in right right now money
markets they had been in the history
been CDs but their money markets and so
what do we do with that money on a
regular basis we pay for the um
recreational therapy uh the team itself
the staff are paid by the state of New
Hampshire but all Resident activities
are paid out of this fund um so that
might be interactive TVs or iPads we do
birthday celebrations Arts projects um
gardening Bingo which is really popular
um holiday
celebrations um we do uh youth groups we
have a sunshine cart because the quality
of life to us is really important and
the veteran go shopping and can get the
same things you or I may want um they go
on um Community trips out to
um like shows sporting events
sightseeing parades plays concerts
restaurants um and as you can see I love
to put the pictures of the residents in
here as well um and then we have other
quality of life aspects we have a town
hall that we hold all of our ceremonies
in in our regular ongoing meetings we
have a Main Street St uh Main Street
store where they can go shopping we have
a library a full library that is covered
all of the cost of that library is
covered by the benefit benefit fund we
have a chapel a barber and a hairdresser
shop we have Courtyards dining rooms
living rooms and something we call the
vet cave which is um if you came for a
tour you would see a giant train uh
setup that uh they often are working on
and then we have computers for them to
access so those are the quality of life
um things that are paid for at those two
accounts yeah thank you let me get into
to the detailed numbers here I I think
on page 174 is there an error because on
in the year 2022 the ending balance was
1.8 million but that means the beginning
balance of 2023 should have been 1.8
something and it's not
yes yes I can see that yes that does
look to be an
error yeah I think I can add I think
when we transition to some of the um
accounting for other items um we might
have just had a a year where something
just transferred wrong we were um
changing sort of the format of this
report a couple years ago but um any any
adjustments that we find through this
review process we just make those
Corrections in the new report and we'll
write a a footnote in the current year
report to explain whatever Corrections
we come across so it does happen Okay
but good question so the balance might
even be 2 million something right um on
our letter um yes yes yes this report is
accurate yes the report that we gave you
is accurate which one uh 2.1 uh 2
point Mr
chair Mr chair this this was a prevalent
this was a prevalent thing a few years
ago and we the committee have made
changes to make sure that if they have
uh obligated the funds you know that it
gets put in the right year and then the
old reports that obligations sometimes
was and sometimes wasn't reflected and
then when they started the new number
then they would reflect it and it caused
all kinds of problems I'm not saying the
old numbers are good but the new numbers
ought to agree they ought to the ending
balance and the the one year should
agree with the beginning balance and the
next year and so if they're not the last
couple of years I wouldn't worry too
much about it
but for what it's
worth yes you're correct the idea was to
make that simplification um to have
those balances roll but this is uh
unfortunately it's a manually input uh
database so sometimes things do get
crossed over and we try to catch them
but we'll make the adjustment going
forward all right thank you
representative wer thank you Mr chair
several years ago before you were there
we found out that they had gone over a
year without paying the fuel oil
bill you probably remember it yes sir I
do
$333,000 yeah how did that occur that
nobody paid attention to
it if I remember
right um the business office sent the
invoices to the commod at the time and
the commod at the time didn't approv
them and then when we changed commants
it came back to surface
so I think the state had to dig in and
pay the bills yes sir that is correct
okay
so does the board look at these things
regularly yes sir we do all right so
hopefully this won't happen again
hopefully we we uh are uh we review
What's called the Exhibit C every month
um at the at the monthly meetings thank
you yes
sir represent of all me thank you um
what's this
87,3 74 this year
used in addition to the
funding um so we had a large donation
left to us from a resident who had
passed and so that is going to we wanted
to use the money to honor him um and so
we are we have a pond on our our our
property and we are going to pave about
half of it around so it's wheelchair
accessible right now really it's not
very safe if somebody went down in a
wheelchair with L uh small pads so we
can have covered gazebos and so that's
going to be an honor of that Resident
who uh left that money for something to
be done and that's how we've we've uh
decided to use that those funds
thank you so those don't go into the
donations don't go into the revenue all
our donations go into the benefit fund
and then we each quarter bring the um
requested funds forward to the board of
managers and ask to spend this amount of
money one of our goals is never to spend
any more than what we have for donations
um we are very fortunate that we have a
lot of support a lot of support uh for
donations at the veterans home so again
we wouldn't normally make a purchase
that large uh our purchases are much
more reasonable um but because we had
Beque this we got this money bequeathed
to us this is how we chose to use
that you you do spend the income though
right I mean the the income yes but we
try not to touch the base of it we we
want those Investments to be there the
in this case it's it's the the total
amount of the donations yes I understand
okay now the balance has been creeping
up over the years is that deliberate or
you just can't think of
other ways to improve the the life of
the residents or well we're very
particular about it because if it's
operational we feel like the state of
New Hampshire should be under the
operations this is really meant to be
donations for the residents um and I
think in the past when we had 225
residents Christmas was bigger because
we had more residents and we're in uh a
deficit with the amount of residents we
can uh bring in because of the Staffing
we are having a tough time to staff our
nursing units so when we have more
residents there's more cost there's more
activities of or cost for an activity
and I think that's what you're seeing
that you're seeing four to five years of
really tough Staffing and not being up
to that
225 residents and and so that's how I
mean I don't want to spend money just to
spend money I want it to be reasonable
and um but our we have really robust
activities so we don't shy away from
that but I think that's what you're
seeing is that creeping up because of
the low census what is the census 1229
today we have 11 pending admissions so
um with my Staffing right now I feel
very comfortable going to 140 residents
beyond that I think we would be risking
quality of care um and it's just
something we can't do until we can have
additional staff hire more nurses
what's the length of the waiting list um
we are spinning that around really
quickly now so we have 20 people on the
actual weight list and 11 of them
already have beds assigned no one is
more on that weight list more than right
now today more than three months we have
applications 27 applications that could
be from day one to uh going through the
process so some of that depends on when
we get medical records from doctors um
when we get the financial records from
families or the applicant so the
application process could take a bit but
we still don't have any applications in
process more than earlier this year in
March so that's really good because
we've had people wait for over a year
before my goal is that when we approve
somebody we can offer them a bed um that
that's the goal so when I came in uh two
and a half years ago we were at 121
we're creeping up to 140 um and it as
long as we continue to have staff we'll
continue to increase our census to meet
that meet all of the
need all right any other questions on
these two
funds no let's go to the member account
okay so the member account is um it's a
trust fund but it's it's for it's the
resident money it's not ours it's not
the state of New Hampshire's it's
actually the resident money so part of
being um you know able to make your own
decisions and have a quality of life is
spending your own money the way you want
to
so this is like a an account within
count there's many count accounts within
that so they have um their um retirement
do uh submitted into that they might
have their social security deposited
into that and each member has their own
account if they choose to do that we do
have members who have chosen to keep
their finances very separate the family
pays a monthly bill they give them
monthly money to spend uh the way they
wish but many of them want to to have
the monies come in they still make all
their own decisions we have uh a very um
thorough process if they want to take
money out we have them sign everybody
signs we have a lot of steps of checks
and balances on how that money works and
if anybody has over $100 in that account
when we have monthly interest which um
not a huge amount but when we do get
that it gets spread through all of the
members so they have the benefit so this
allows them to continue to manage their
own funds we're not telling them how to
do that um and uh this is one of the
things that they can do to still become
be remain
independent and so you keep separate sub
accounts for each individual so yes
representative Aly thank you I apologize
I was still trying to find the places I
wanted to write things down when you
rattled off I think it was the
percentage of the expense es your
expenses that was from ran board at 32%
but then the I missed the VA and I
missed entirely the other support I
couldn't find it in there um it's I
should put a page number on these
shouldn't I so after the resident data
dashboard it's the next one how we're
supported so 39% of our Revenue comes
from the uh Veteran Affairs get that
oh I missed this one so maybe there you
go oh yeah 32% from the residents
themselves and then
29% from the general funds I'll just
keep it open to that and that can change
so the more prevailing rate residents we
have we get a higher fund uh a higher
payment um reimbursement daily and uh
with the packed act being signed into
place we're seeing more veterans have a
high High um they're qualifying for a
higher disability rating and so there
are many more that are uh being being
moved from that basic rate which is um a
lower rate to the higher rate to the
prevailing rate so it it really can
still change this is you know this is
today's numbers this is the percentage
of how it works
today and if a resident passes away then
this money is returned to their family
absolutely their account is we have 90
days by the VA regulation we're licensed
through the VA we have 90 days to clear
their account meaning that we have taken
all charges that are going to be taken
out of that and then send that back to
the families so um we're really we're
really faster than that um we often get
complimented when we have our yearly
survey through the VA for processing
them much quicker uh that way the funds
go back to the family
okay representative M me and if um you
have somebody who can't pay either came
in that way or I yes yes so we uh the
state of New Hampshire uh pays for uh
the uh National Guard National Guard is
not recognized if they haven't deployed
and they haven't met the minimum
requirements of the VA they do not see
them in their in their view as their a
veteran but they don't pay for them
under the long-term care um act but the
new state of New Hampshire does we we
respect in our thankful for their
service so sometimes we have uh I think
we have three or four veterans right now
that are National Guard uh that's not
paid by the VA so that will skew our
numbers a little bit of how it all
breaks down because it's not just one
person it's the whole
pot so represent W is that true of all
the National Guard people that that the
VA doesn't recognize their service it's
not recognize their service it's for the
predum rate of Nursing Home Care so they
do not uh the government does not pay
unless they've been deployed and they
have to have certain things that get
checked off the box if they served for
you know 20 years and never were
deployed um at your because it's a State
National Guard is State uh so they look
at it that way uh some other state
veterans homes do the same thing we do
the state covers the cost so we still
pay for them um but it it's something
that is a Cornerstone of of the New
Hampshire veterans home to serve all
veterans they still have to be a veteran
they get a DD214 they're still
classified as a veteran it's just for
this pay Source this program they do get
a DD214 yes thank you thank
you what's a
DD214 okay she asked what's the
DD214 uh the DD214 is the discharge
papers from the federal government the
honorable discharge or any discharge any
can be any good summary of your service
yes we got
it do members ever tip a staff no we
can't accept money okay
yes we don't accept money we don't
accept gifts it which can be tough for
them because they want to do things for
us but we just we can't do that it's uh
it's against the rules it's against the
the process and so we always tell them
uh something else is a nice thing to sit
with them and just chat um we get a lot
of donated cards so sometimes they'll
just write us a card uh it has no cost
to it but it has a value to us that
means more than a tip thank other
questions seeing none thank you very
much thank you sir thank you all right I
see I see commissioner
a
yes commissioner don't think that I'm
walking out on you I do have a doctor's
appointment in Rochester but they are
recording this just for me so that I can
be able to uh go back in and watch this
so don't think I'm sliding you
okay all right so he's on let's
see um what page is he on 240 page 240 I
think
maybe
yes uh
revolving fund there it is
okay all
right he has
many this is the the bulk of what we're
doing today oh is that right
R by the way how did they get away with
not paying the heat for a year and they
kept it warm over there you
know I guess their vendor thought they
were good for it
all right thank you and I know you need
no introduction but go ahead for the
record Frank GBL Commissioner of
Education Tammy Valen Court CFO for
Education thank you all
right do we want to just go one by one
sure and I'll just answer questions that
you may
have okay
all right
copers so this this one is mostly used
for um purchase of uh legislative books
for the legislature and the department
the rule books of the education laws is
how we use these funds in addition to
renting in addition to renting copers
that then we back we charge Revenue out
to the various programs to pay for the
rental of those copers in the paper
involved that's kind of a net yes so if
you didn't have to print those books how
much would we
save uh I think those books cost around
$122,000 yeah 12,000 and they're going
up and you'll notice that last year got
skinnier because it's hard to find an
editor who's willing to find all the
annotations that are just specific to
education rules but I can tell you
they're very popular and very useful for
a lot of
people educ committee always wants
to I know they do but I mean doesn't
mean we have to do it they go to allus
what's that do they go to all they do
not we provide all the saus we do a
digital copy as well that we put on
thumb drives and we mail everybody a
thumb drive of the
laws yeah and and we send those not just
to the seus but oftentimes people say
can we have the education laws and we
have these thumb drives that we send out
that are part of this cost as well
but a lot cheaper than a book who is
that a lot cheaper than than a book it
is but there's a lot of people who want
to Mark in the book and many legislators
who prefer to have those books
so right okay do do does
that what explains that the expenses got
a lot higher for three years and then
went down again yeah so it's um
basically finding we had a tough time
finding even a publisher who was willing
to go through the process it used to be
done I forget one of the the popular
legal publishing companies and then it
was difficult to find somebody and the
price just there like if you want it
done this is what it's going to cost so
we reduced the scope to really focus on
specific laws but it just was because
again it's very limited the number that
we are publishing so they're kind of
like for that we don't know if we want
to do it
so and that's when we went to the thumb
drives because of the cost that's when
we went to the thumb drives exactly
because we used to distribute a lot more
well I'm trying to look at several
things at once this one is the one that
was handed out by everybody I can't find
your copy of it so I using my copy of it
okay so I'm just working out of the book
that I think you all have yeah but then
there's 2024 numbers yeah the 2024 went
down too so right that's not in your
book yeah your handout is a year has a
year extra information so I was at
16,000 last year is my expenses it went
down a little bit I'm not sure why okay
gotta
now should we worry that the balance in
this fund is is declining or are you
just going to increase these uh little
charges yes so we try to balance the
fund so that we don't have an excessive
amount and so we will go from like
charging two cents a page for printing
to three cents and then we'll bounce
back to two if we start to generate a
lot of Revenue
okay I guess this is reasonable yeah
other questions no okay let's go to the
next one interpreter
certification so is there some reason
this is not handled by
oplc if there is I don't know what the
reason is why it's not handled by oplc
we don't I don't think we have an
objection to moving over to oplc
um okay yeah I don't know why why it is
at this agency there's not a ton of
activity going on there
um you know it would be good to have
more interpreters probably uh it was at
education because we do rely on
interpreters particularly needing to get
licensed interpreters for the schools if
for our kids who are in need of that
support
um okay there's not a ton of
activity and it it can't have a
full-time employee with this kind of
number number no none of these have
fulltime I don't yeah we don't have any
full I maybe some of them do but we
don't have any employees this is just
all handled by the accounting department
or people with other
responsibilities
okay so possibility of of a action would
be to move this to
oplc yeah
okay the ending balance it's been going
up a lot over the years it has right
because we get our we're it's I think we
what's my Revenue source on this is the
fees that people are paying so maybe
those fees could be reduced those are
those fees belong to oplc not to us so
they get sent
OPC I believe they're all that's where
they're licensed and then that I gets
transferred the revenue kind ofs
transferred over to my account is that
how we're doing
I'm yeah I don't know how I get
it okay we don't have an we don't have
an educator credential called
interpreter certificate
I
see yeah and oplc is pretty good about
balancing fees and costs right
so if this balance got too big they
would fix it yeah and we try to do the
same thing for the ones that are in our
space yeah all right it's been it's grow
it's doubled in five years
yeah
okay other questions oh
okay the nasmith
fund now this is a private
trust corre and that's important to
notice in a whole bunch of these they
are private trusts they were put in by a
will
usually um they're a little difficult to
change this as well you'll see we get
this giant income in 2022 where they did
a mark to Market on all of the
Investments that were being held there
that's in a couple of our private
funds
um
wow much of this the work like so we do
individuals who are in need of Aid and
support and
maintenance um who are Indigent blind
are generally eligible for either Social
Security Disability Administration which
the department administers or vocation
rehabilitation services if they're
working so um there's a variety of
programs to support them in addition to
this there's also the future in sight
nonprofit and a lot of the future
Insight work we have several contracts
with them through vocation
Rehabilitation to support this type of
activity because it it seems like there
ought to be more use for the the fund
again but I have because I have another
funding source I'm I think I probably
default to the vocation Rehabilitation
funding source as opposed to this
fund
so I think it's extremely difficult to
wind I know it's extremely difficult to
wind these down I mean if you're get to
the nonprofit world and just see if
individuals want grants to do this work
um to support it right we don't have any
staff member assigned in here or
anything else
so um if you think that that would be a
worthwhile exercise we can do
that yes uh represent um yes thank you
um just looking at the um the revenue
for
2023 it's surprising to me that that's
about one less than onethird of the year
before when interest rates have been
High um why is that so that's because in
2022 there was rebalancing by the
treasur of the funds where they marked
them to Market so that's why you got
this you know on $468,000 you generated
$178,000 of Revenue um and that was
because they did they had all these Book
value um equities that they marked to
Mark in and so it just looks like a a
substantive increase in the return on
funds that here I see yeah now there's
another fund for the blind coming up
later yeah and is there could could
maybe that one be folded into this one
so the other fund for the blind let me
go back it's you could vending stands
yeah the vending stands so that's
actually a very specific program
basically the legislature has granted to
um The Blind Association the ability to
operate uh machine vending in the rest
areas in the state um and so that is
what that fund is doing so I'm not sure
if they could be conflated or not um
since well this one
is is funded by the general fund right
uh it is which oneing the vending stand
by the vending stands yeah there's
vending no there's vending machines and
the only difference that you'll see is
that we were able to in 23 24 we
suspended the fees because when Co
happened many of these vendors got hurt
and so uh they lost Revenue
buy so we gave a like several years
reprieve on the fees because there was
plenty of funding in the accounts to be
able to support it but you generally
spend from both of these funds for the
same things yes um I don't know if I
would call that the same things I mean
these are you know um very
entrepreneurial individuals on the
vending set like these are guys who are
running vending machines right and we're
basically helping them be G somewhat
gamefully employed relative to that as
opposed to the other is more of kind of
a Aid fund for indent individuals in
some type of a
need oh are you saying from the vending
fund you're spending to give back to the
people running the vending machines yeah
it's basically just a fun to basically
kind of collect and support collect and
support
oh and and we buy equipment like we'll
buy equipment for them or
yeah oh so so right representative me
yeah
so did the general fund give any money
to them at the beginning of this it
looks like I don't know how this was
initially funded yeah it's been around
for a while a long time
but but it is not a private trust this
one is not a private trust it's just an
operational fund as opposed to the other
one is a private trust and I think has a
little bit more specific use of
funds but but it seems weird we're
charging the money and giving them back
money what what's the point of that
right
so yeah we're buying the equipment from
them so we buy it in
yeah I I would say that some vendors are
more profitable than others and so we
are collecting a fee that then gets
dispersed amongst all of the vend and I
call them vendors
the
The Operators thank you and um and then
we turn around and we purchase vending
machines for them um and then they're
responsible they go stock it and make
sure that it's operational and keep it
rolling so we're basically setting them
up in business for those who want
there's not a tremendous demand first of
all vending machines are waning um you
know secondarily there's not a ton of
individuals who want to do this but
those who come to us have been at it for
a while or if there's a new person
coming in they're saying like I want to
try and earn some money with this this
is an eligible program for them
so okay but you said in the future needs
section there was something
um that you would in the future support
aspiring entrepreneurs by providing
essential resources training and startup
cap capital and
uh and enrich our communities through
diverse
businesses it sounds like you're trying
to go away from just the vending
machines no no it's just the vending
machines it's all this diverse meaning
like you know maybe different types of
products through those vending machines
because there's not really another like
they own and they have the reservation
on the vending machine real estate in
the state rest areas
yeah in state buildings and state
buildings
okay and state buildings yes the ones
downstairs yes there rather they aren't
downstairs that you have to go variety
of places but near the G yeah yeah I
mean you know like if if we wanted to
wind this down we could just not add
anybody new to the program and just let
it attenuate while the current vendors
who are using it or doing it but if a
new today if a new person came to us and
wanted to get set up and started we
would start them
oh so um UNH would also be involved in
this I don't know if we have stuff at
UNH or not I'm not sure I just I know
mostly the the um state buildings and
the uh rest areas and I think the rest
areas are the ones that are most
prolific for
them is there a full-time employee
running this program there's no
employees running it okay do we even
allocate time to it I'm not sure Patty
doesn't work on it but do we charge any
time to it I no I don't believe so I
don't think we even charge any any
administrative time I don't think we
charge anything to this I
see all right we we'll consider this one
I guess all right and then you might
want to consider that with the John nbet
if you
were because you had we can't really do
anything together with
them I mean would you so when what is
the the desire of the legislature do you
want me to try and go find some
nonprofits and we just make grants to
nonprofits to serve these individuals I
mean you mentioned future insight I have
a variety of contracts with Future
Insights but I could make grants to them
to support you know they can make a
proposal say here's how I'm going to use
the money and we'll award them you know
my income is about $40,000 a year to
support these individuals we could do
that at $40,000 a year you'd be getting
taking this
fund unless we get a major I could just
operate yeah I could just like I could
do 50 000 and bring it down some or I
could you know but a lot of this revenue
is driven off of the return on the
investment right on the fund balance so
what I'm saying is I could do a grant
equal to whatever my revenue is in the
prior year I just grant it out to folks
you know maybe minus a an inflationary
Factor
yeah yeah there's an appro annual
appropriation to you and that's what's
increasing this balance up from 425
years ago to 685 yeah the appropriation
is just the interest on the Investments
yeah yeah right so that's what I'm
suggesting is that we would
just you know grant that to someone to
support this the mission yeah of Miss at
least the amount of interest each year
there's a way
to to get people to use it well for yeah
the
blind but again like I can like there's
you know most of these individuals end
up getting plugged into the uh vocation
Rehabilitation programming and Social
Security Disability Administration
programs and so you don't see a lot of
you know especially you're dealing with
indent folks like there's other social
service programs that are wrapped around
these individuals which is probably why
you're not turning we haven't been
turning to this because we've already
got something dealing with
that and those other programs have all
the infrastructure and process
you know to to get people to plug them
in to move them through whereas this
would be kind of an ad hoc thing and
we're not charging administrative fees
to this and I don't know if we want to
so would it make sense for this to be
part of the HHS Department instead of
Education are they the ones dealing with
blind people more often or not so we do
through Vocational Rehabilitation we
have a blind services division oh okay
yeah so we do support the
individuals with those
disabilities yeah I live in Lebanon New
Hampshire and they took all of the State
offices and moved them to Claremont and
then moved some of them out of Claremont
to
Newport uh which means that most people
can't get to them if they're you say
that one more time I missed the
beginning
on
on my city of Lebanon uh used to have a
lot of State Services most of those
Services have moved out and a number of
them are in only in Newport at this
point you can't get there there
accessible yeah yeah without a car
because there isn't much bus service in
Sullivan County there is a little now
between us and them to Claremont only I
can tell you like I feel confident if I
put out a you know a request for Grant
proposals that we would get more than
one hopefully um you know and then we
could adjudicate them in terms of their
alignment with the trust fund
Mission
okay yeah I would just add that if the
goal is to eliminate the fund the
dedicated fund like you can still do the
activity you can still if the fund get
can't do it don't have the funds right
You' have to accept that other income
into your
budget that otherwise you have to use
the dedicated fun fund mechanism so if
your goal is to eliminate the fund we
have to eliminate funding the underlying
but if you eliminate if we eliminate
this fund then it just goes away then I
can tell you I have other programs in
place to support these individuals so I
can do it if you want to eliminate I
just don't know if you can I you'd have
to check no no I don't think you can
you'd have to eliminate the legislation
spending it down a so is difficult but
right now it's just
growing right for the NZ I thought you
were talking about the other one right
so I guess I I I was talking about the
vendor fees I don't know I guess we
switched off of the vendor uh oh yeah
yeah that was the vendor fee the vendor
fee program doesn't need to be a
dedicated fund is all I'm saying yeah
but this one does when it is you have to
spend years going through the AG's
office to get it removed when it's
totally useless all right so why don't
we just make a recommendation that he
tries to uh Grant
the the income from this fund yeah okay
yeah I think that's a way to keep it
from from grow growing out okay all
right special teachers
competency um so this fund we're
primarily using in support of our
teacher of the year program which has
actually grown substantively um you know
we started we were getting maybe 15
applicants a year uh two years ago we
had over 300 applicants 100 people
finished it out the difficulty is with
the growth we also have um you know
there's more interest in external
support as well so we basically are
trying to balance this and then what
happens is we know what kind of Revenue
we're going to get but then we are able
to raise other funds to be basically
support the program
um and and we don't want to get out over
our skis like the program is running
really well right now so but so I think
you know when I was putting this
together there are more activities that
we can do with these funds Beyond just a
teacher of the year that's how we've
been using it so we'll just expand the
uses of
them so you're getting really good
Revenue here right I mean you only have
200 and something thousand you're
getting 20,000 a year of Revenue well
that was the year uh well 300,000 we're
getting 20 because interest rates have
gone up if you go back a little bit we
were at to 10 and then we did have the
marked Market that took place on some of
these funds so yeah but the expenses are
a lot less
yes and mostly because we're generating
revenue from other sources to offset the
expenses for the
programs oh so you're saying teacher of
the year spends more than the $5,000
this is just what ends up ultimately
flowing through I
see all
right you can leave those other funds
where they are and just draw more funds
out of here then or take those donations
and put them someplace else yeah yeah
but again as a popular program people
want to support it
so so you're getting donations all the
time well we we solicit donations um
from commercial companies for this oh I
see because vendors are interested in
that and do you talk to the teachers
colleges teachers teachers
colleges um people need it yeah yeah so
we we have not we use this only in the
DOI area we could push that's what I'm
saying there's we could more broadly
apply These funds if we wanted to to try
to bleed them
down yeah you I'm sure we would be able
to find you know expanded usage for the
funds yeah have an undergraduate
teaching fellowship or something
something of the year right or or just
somebody who is the the outstanding
student of the year or something you
could do that
yeah okay trying not to make it too
complicated probably because then right
now it doesn't attract the
administrative funds um but then as we
build the more programs we put in here
at a certain point then we're going to
say like okay it needs to attract some
administrative fees associated with it
so far we've not done that
gotcha all right other questions on this
one a lot of stuff to keep track of a
lot of little funds here truthfully like
you want to get rid of all these
right there are two
here that I thought five years ago I was
going to get Mo or three years ago that
I was going to get moved to the
university system this one was you know
quite frankly you can if if this was
swept I don't have a need for this fund
and I don't I don't think we touched the
trust funds that are created through
Wills I'm not I'm just saying some of
these other right we're kind of bouncing
around but some of the other
programmatic things if you can absorb
them you can get rid of the dedicated
fun yeah so I don't think we have any
reason I think she had moved on on
special teachers competency fund it says
this is a trust fund yes it doesn't Okay
so I can't touch that it doesn't say
whose trust fund right it was it a
there's a difference between the the
word trust gets used quite frequently um
for various reasons but the trusts that
I'm referring to are legal will-based
trusts that you spoken to the state
treasurer about so if it's not that and
it's just dedicated by dedicated fund
statute and the underlying legislation
you can do whatever you want with it yes
s can we find
out who's who started this
fund whether it belongs to a deceased
individual or got be something yeah okay
so yeah we can look up the history of
this RSA right the
RSA yeah okay so to sweep that one
you'll figure that out okay yes all
right good and then when we want to
sweep it then we just tell you that we
don't need to
we have to put it in our bill okay so
you need to tell us then what are you
going to do uh within a month or
something yeah find something let go
through Steve right okay um yeah so can
we ask for simultaneously ask for an
appropriation for Teacher of the
Year for getet it yeah I need $15,000 a
year for a teacher of the year you can
put that in yes in the budget okay
Harriet Huntress funds Harriet Huntress
and hadie Livy it's thing and and you
know like so we've not had interest in
these we're happy to try and generate
interest I think the last time I did
this we tried to generate interest and
didn't get a lot these might be good
ones to move over to Keem yeah um I I
talked but these are will to the state
but can you move them I don't know when
the contr controller of the University
system was here I informed her about
these two and she went away to do
something about it she hasn't me yet but
I will anticipate that call I follow
with
us I think she's now in a different role
at the University system she is
yeah Chancellor or something Kathy
preventure Oren
right it was Kathy proventure that met
with them a couple years ago it was
proventure so was I know so we need to
poke her is that the the hadti was a
Beque to the state of New State of New
Hampshire yeah so it doesn't have to go
to you we could delegate the activity
like delegates just clear the funds each
year say I've earned $2,500 you can
award it as a
scholarship at those two univer two
School period two Education Department
of Education Department of Education yes
it is so Harry it was Beed to the
Department of Education ah py was just
State of New
Hampshire yeah but you should be
spending we still could pass through the
funds yeah I think you know when we go
to look for
individuals it's such a small amount of
funds that everybody's like oh my gosh
this is going to be impossible to
organize and find a student
that can use up the funds yeah but I'm
sure the colleges can do it right yeah
but again even at the college level like
if you're earning you know $2,400 or
$4,600 to convene a committee to accept
applications and review the applications
and decide how you're going to do them
after a while it just becomes more
difficult than the
effort no I just
meant
um if you gave this money to Keen into
Plymouth yeah right as a check right but
even for them then they like in other
words they'd have to plug well they get
checks all the time from people right I
mean donations but they have to then
come back and show us that it was used
for a
need because he's a St employee you know
what kind of student did they talk about
and still be responsible for the
accounting right yeah like they can't
just use it to plow the roads they got
they can't put their general
fund they have to find a qualified
student that ke or
Plymouth but they have financial aid and
all this sort of stuff they do but then
the question is so how does why does one
student get it or versus another student
like how do they award it
and if it's a grant do you then open it
up and let people apply for it and then
you got to process the applications I
just think that's what's I know that the
last time I went through this process we
had that conversation and we had very
little interest for the amount of money
in in taking over the responsibilities
associated with it this this is already
done for the 529 program given out about
1,200 per student I mean we're happy to
go back to them and see if they have a a
already existing scholarship program
than this can contribute to yeah yeah
and all these colleges get an amount
that goes to a endowment fund
specifically to be used for this 529
program okay we can do that right okay
so we can do that both for the Harriet
as well as the had fund
yes we deal with thousands of
applications they're already got them
stacked up over in treasury what what do
they have over there the funds for the
529 program that comes from Fidelity
right this was this was quite a happy
thing back 28 years ago we had a
secretary or we had a Treasurer that
gets the law here's a 529 program
taxfree parents can put money aside blah
blah blah she uh the treasurer makes up
an application form sends it to the IRS
and says is this acceptable is this a
good form just meet all your criteria
they put that form on their website so
that anybody across the country that
went to the IRS to look up what's the
what's the tax exempt thing I can put in
all went to New Hampshire so only 3% of
the money that's in this program comes
from people in New Hampshire the other
97% is from all over the
country and because there's billions
that Fidelity is there managing we get
125 billion million 125 million a year
it's
incredible surprise they don't even know
where they're sending their but now a
lot of the other states are doing the
same thing so yeah so now now we're
number four or number five depending on
which level you look at because I think
Virginia jumped in and of course they
give people tax exemption when they put
the money in it's tax from the state tax
as well as the federal tax so all the
other states California New York they're
catching on yeah so but some of the
people that have already been in our
program some of them are allowed to
exempt it from their state taxes even if
the money goes into program okay but we
can find we'll find a scholarship fund
to give this to even if it's a third
party scholarship fund and we'll just
take the income and pass it through to
them so if they're already doing it
exactly that's what you need is
infrastructure yeah yeah I don't mind
giving miss preventure a call and d call
Kathy okay yeah
all right you'll do it all right I can
all
right it won't change the fund here
because we'll still have the fund you'll
still have the fund you'll just send
them a check once a year you know like
that
yeah stud going or she will yeah I
suppose building
authority School
building so this is basically
uh um you know $8 a day of expenses yeah
we don't need it right I mean nobody on
the school building authority has ever
asked for reimbursement of expenses we
still do have a school building
authority they still do meet they still
do review applications they have driven
all over the state but nobody's asked
for money all right so this one should
be eliminated I think it can kill this
yeah and where do we put the little bit
of money it has and the teacher of the
year program that we're also going to
kill
um that's actually that's actually
General funds we could lapse it back to
the general fund general
fund 5,000 a
year no no 5,000 total well that's B
177,000 but we were adding 5,000 in
there because we were amping up the
building aid program we thought people
would be asking for reimbursement but
nobody has so right right
okay yeah it the 5,000 a year came from
your budget somewhere yeah somewhere in
our budget I think ah okay it was I was
assuming it was General funds and some
it is in through the budget process yeah
well or probably education trust fund I
don't think it came through the trust I
think it just came out of just general
appro general fund okay all right good
we'll get rid of that one all right
teacher certific
this is my main fund and this is the one
I need this is basically for uh educator
lure funds um and we basically on a
regular basis are trying to balance the
amount of the license fees we've reduced
fees and some stuff we just went through
a rebalancing of fees because some take
a little bit more effort to do than
other ones and we try to keep this thing
not you can see we bled it down because
it had gotten fairly large and we're
trying to keep it just a parody makes
Tammy nervous that it's come down she
wishes that it wouldn't come down but
we're not going to let it come down too
low but we're not going to keep Point
your money that we don't it's not our
money it belongs to the licensees
so losing teacher jobs every year so
fewer teachers licensing yeah although
that's not the case in New Hampshire we
have this I mean two years ago we had
our highest ever licensure this year
we're going to have our second highest
ever licensure really yeah even though
there's not that many jobs um unless we
just don't have a lot of the shortage
that individual that other states have
suffered because we've created a lot of
alternative Pathways for individuals who
are retired or want a second career or
career switchers to be able to get into
the education profession which has
attracted a number of people to get seek
licensure
so retiring and collecting of Revenue
somewhere else then we pay them yeah but
if they but again I mean it's actually a
good gig because you have you know
people are living longer they want to be
engaged and they want to participate in
in society and their communities so they
can get you know uh they can do that
this way Charlie B doing this retired
from the Air Force 20 some years into
teaching put in enough years to collect
to get two P re so normally they just
retire from Massachusetts school system
and come up here and then tap our school
system and then they get two
pensions now teachers are required to
have bachelor's degrees to be certified
or no they are depends on the different
certifications have different
requirements we also have like a par
professional educator certification that
requires different stuff so it depends
on the
individual educator certification that
they're seeking and what they're
required to have many of them require
master's
degrees I remember years ago when we
talked about the
alternative certification we looking at
people like guy comes out of the Air
Force he went in there became a mechanic
he was good at explaining it to
everybody else so he he ended up
full-time 15 of his 20 years teaching
the systems to all the other mechanics
and and sometimes the pilots I went
through coures for that every time we
went through a new airplane here's the
hydraulic system this this this and so
these guys 15 years of teaching
experience some complicated subjects
they said why can't this guy get a
teaching certificate he's what he's been
doing for 15 years and I think some of
them were able to do it right well so we
have created alternative Pathways so
those individuals can get into education
in the state of New Hampshire which has
I mean this year we crossed over a line
so we certified more Educators this year
through alternative Pathways than
through educator preparation programs
just because there are fewer younger
people choosing to go to the four and
five-year college degree route now we
have those programs and they're there
and they're supporting kids but there's
fewer students available but they're I
mean I refer to it as kind of the uh the
hidden resource in New Hampshire are
retired individuals right we've got a
aging population we've got a lot of
Brain Trust sitting on the sidelines and
through these alternative PA Pathways
were able to get them engaged in their
communities and in helping the Next
Generation but but specifically if such
a person did not have a bachelor's
degree in something or other could they
still get certified they can we have
alternative Pathways for them to be able
to do that in fact they do have some
pedagogical educational requirements
that we require of them um and it's over
a three-year period that they do it so
essentially you file a plan you have a
mentor which is your super attendance so
we make sure these people are effective
in the classrooms and then we put
together kind of these bundled course
options with Keen with plmouth and with
the UNH at the College of professional
studies that they go through kind of a
depending on what certification you're
going to do we've already pre-ordained
like if you take this block of courses
that will complete your pedagogical
requirements for your certification in
three years but they're working while
they're going through that
process so are those courses
valuable or not uh we hope
so well I mean the difficulty is that
you're trying to decide is there a
correlation what you find is even
individuals who come through educator
preparation programs do mean that you're
a good educator right right um really
that's one of the advantages of the
alternative certifications is you put
someone in the classroom they have a
mentor who's assigned to guide them
through that three-year process and you
know you know this person's going to be
effective or this person's not whether
or not they've come through the cuz cuz
coming through the educator preparation
program is not necessarily indicative of
someone who will ultimately be a good
classroom
teacher okay does mean that they've gone
through that certification process now
is somebody can be laid off if they're
not effective well they would refer to
is it's non-renewed and so on an annual
basis they generally you know at the
beginning of the year they have a
contract for academic year and then in
April they do the renewals or
non-renewals and so individuals who are
not successful generally are not renewed
gotcha
Okay so we've got this problem that the
ending
balance is declining no does that have
anything to do with having more people
in in alternative Pathways that and you
charging them less so it does somewhat
so there bringing this balance down was
a deliberate move um in terms of trying
to bring it down we reduce some fees but
we did just readjust the fees and we now
will be charging more for the
alternative Pathways because they do
consume additional resources and so
hopefully we're going to be charging the
uh the amount that those um consume so
that I would suspect that this balance
that you see here is B pretty much just
going to level out now I think I'm
comfortable like I didn't I just thought
a million dollar sitting on the sideline
didn't make sense it's not our money it
belongs to the license holders um but we
do need some working capital to keep
this thing running and so uh we're just
adjusting fees to try and keep that
balanced I me another thing we
introduced recently was uh we're
required to do background checks now for
uh individuals and um so we charge a fee
for the background check um but we had
startup costs associated with that so
there weren't a ton initially but now
there's more and so that's reaching its
parity in terms of the number of
background checks that we're doing uh to
pay for the the resources that are are
in there
does the revenue and expenses happen all
through the year or are they kind of
connected to to the school year or
something yeah so the renewal is every
three years um the licenses renew in
June um we've actually done quite a good
job uh encouraging Educators to
accelerate when they apply for that
renewal but certainly a big chunk of it
is coming in um you know in the fourth
quarter of the fiscal
year and then you spend over the whole
year you spend over the next year
exactly
okay but you can't get rid of that fund
and you
don't
no
allate okay Career School another fund
so this is you know fee based um so we
are required by Statute to license
career schools there's a definition of
what that is um and again here we have
done some work on fee structure to try
and minimize that and and not generate a
surplus um and we would adjust the fees
to try and you know just keep it level
set but this is where that activity goes
through and is the licensing done yearly
or um it depends on the licensure you
know that the individual has but I think
it's a annual license that they have
sure yeah I don't recall if it's if they
might have like a fiveyear license cycle
not exactly sure I don't I don't
remember I'm sorry
is this another thing that oplc does but
this is very different than oplc because
this is actually licensure of
educational programming yeah um we have
tried to minimize the government
footprint on this particular program by
reducing requirements um down to a
minimum in the role that we see
ourselves and what the legislature has
put into the statute is really that
we're just uh more of a of a fiduciary
role in the sense that
um you know if if one of these schools
disappears in the middle of the night um
you know so we had changed the rules uh
you know in the law a couple of years
ago um focusing on that and requiring
the schools essentially we just we
requiring the schools to have a shity
bond so that if they've collected
tuition and they disappear and and I
don't know if you recall a couple years
ago we had a one of the nursing schools
um disappeared in the middle of the
night and uh and we had a shy Bond and
no students were uh you know lost any
funds because we basically were able to
collect on that Bond and pay off all the
students that had paid tuition so all
that the students lost at that point in
time was time and their educational
trajectory because they were halfway
through a semester and the school closed
down but there was not a financial
loss what happened in uh 2023 despite
the
expenses just depends probably on the
number of um renewals and stuff that we
have I don't I don't know the answer to
that I can go search that out and and
let you
know
okay this one does have staff in
it right so did it have an extra person
for a year or something like that I
don't know the answer to that okay all
right but maybe find out yeah I can find
out and let you know now at the last
sentence here says must meet
120% yeah so are you not meeting this
120%
I don't know what that means well
generally for the retirement system so
when when you have a bunch of employees
and you say this is how much the
employees cost so we got to put this at
the cost of the but then they say 120%
because the invisible cost of the
retirement system sort
of I don't know the I tend to think this
is
Professional Licensing for a long period
of time charged more than the cost of
the licensing and returned money to the
general fund right so before we had oplc
if you were a li a doctor we we charged
the doctors a licensing fee that was
120% or
125% of the cost of Licensing them and
the extra money got went to the general
fund so maybe this is something similar
you're supposed to be charging 120% of
the cost of Licensing these schools back
and lapsing some money back I don't have
the answer to that yeah we can go find
out though I think that a lot of that
excess money went to pay went to pay for
uh groups like midwives that weren't
producing as much money as they
cost well yeah before o opcf that it
became more difficult to figure out what
to do about licensing midwives and
people like that I mean I don't know it
seemed like a lot of this is like where
schools like CDL Drivers heavy equipment
drivers um you know those folks um sure
who's coming through many of these
schools yeah does PE ring
schools does the higher education
commission get paid for out of this no
they don't they'll see there's a
separate fund associated with with that
coming up this is purely the career
schools higher education fund has
oversight relative to the rules for the
career schools um but they they don't
collect fees out of
us okay all right so we'll we'll look at
RSA 188 G col9
okay all right Orphans of veterans how
about
that this we just award every year it's
you know we advertise it we Regen now
it's there's not these
are students in New Hampshire higher
education
institutions that are children of um you
that are orphans of Orphans and
widows and we publicize this extensively
um and uh seems like we get one kid you
know and they'll stick in there for
three years but then we don't find
anybody else who fits the
qualifications we have to be a a New
Hampshire kid who's going to a
university system whose parents served
and died of a service related injury
right
so it's not there's not that many of
them I see and you're putting 10,000 in
your budget every year to we are because
we hope that we can keep finding them
and okay we award as many as we can find
gotcha and the balance keeps on going up
because we can't find the kids usually
only one person that they find so you
might skip a year I found in 23 I had
two kids you know but it's only 2500 is
the most they can get any correct yeah
but it is really flexible Grant in the
sense that um like this allows them to
pay like we don't limit this to only
tuition or something like that so they
can pay for books they can pay for their
housing they can pay for a lot of
different expenses associated with their
education it is literally
a you know a open and his scholarship so
maybe it would make sense for us to
raise the the amount paid to 5,000
instead of 25 I know there'll be some
happy kids because the cost has
certainly gone up over the years right
same for a long time yeah that would be
the alternative to cutting the budget
amount yeah exactly who would make the
decision to make it more than 25000 us I
guess it would be you and I would just
say if you can say up to would be good
because suppose I get like 10 kids all
of a sudden right right yeah
all right so that's I mean it's probably
the number is
in is in the some RSA no remember being
in a group that gave $100 scholarship
doing that for 30
years so have a grandkid that's that's
done this it ain't worth this time 100
bucks to write the essay
yeah you know got he got to send you his
his uh his of his grades and all this
kind of stuff and get the college to
send
it okay bucks I'm not yeah all right so
we could change it to up to
$5,000
okay
yeah right we've talked about the
vending machines
yes um so the next is my higher
education Commission
okay higher
education sometimes these titles are
very difficult to
understand why how why do we um get to
inspect out of state public and private
institutions is it because a New
Hampshire scholarship student has gone
there or uh so if it's just if it's
purely out of state we would not be
doing that but many schools these days
are now offering online programming as
well um and that's actually there's an
organization called Sarah uh who is
charging the fees and circles them back
through
um you know so that was a a change that
happened in the OB Obama administration
that basically said if you're offering
education in those states you have to be
approved by those individual states so
then some enterprising people created
that sah organization to create national
accreditation so that's how that process
you through um but what happens then is
if you're Purdue and you got students in
New
Hampshire uh you're offering education
in New Hampshire to students in New
Hampshire that's how you create that
Nexus so this looks like you're doing a
good job of balancing revenue and
expenses I mean we have adjusted these
fees a couple of times but that's the
objective is to just kind of balance
it
okay other
questions good okay next
robotics so this is a grant that I get
through the legislature and every year
we fully awarded and it gets fully
expended the only reason that you see
any balance is because there's a overlap
between the fun I get the funds and then
they Grant the funds and then the school
use them and then they apply for them um
but all the funds 100% of these funds
have been granted and 100% of these
funds will be
used to your point if I need a dedicated
fund I don't know if I need a dedicated
fund I could run it through an account
or something like that if it's easier
for you all initially it was set up as a
dedicated
fund I think representative major wanted
it that way who did representative major
okay he was the guy who campaigned for
that a very popular program I mean I've
had you know we I get calls on this one
all the
time so expensive equipment and then you
see the contest where they go and smash
each other they're awesome huh yeah we
don't have any smashing contests we try
and keep is a little bit better than
that
but but it's it's slowly creeping up
here right I think it's just like the
lapsing of the funds because we do a
grant to the school and then they have
time to be able to use that if they
don't use it we've got a backlog of
schools that apply for them so there's
no like 100% of the funds are granted to
the schools and we give them a a time
frame to when they have to use it by and
if they haven't used it and we give them
you know some amount of time so it would
kind come up in the beginning remember
we just started this in
2020 um and so again it's just kind of
the carryover funds
effect
okay so um and we don't charge any
administrative fees in this one and
people who participate don't pay for
things or no uh so describe I don't know
what you mean by that students who
participate the students are not paying
for it um we do require that the schools
that receive grants are required to have
an industry
partner um which generally comes with
some type of a contribution or something
like that so the teams themselves are
getting additional funds into their
teams um but the students themselves are
I'm not I've never heard of anybody
being required to pay gotta
okay all
right Public School school
infrastructure fund another um fund that
we use consistently and we have a long
wait list um if if funds that have been
granted have not been used
so
yeah where's the million it's only for K
to2 security and internet conne activity
as far as I can
tell where' they put
in keeping it in to us as we spend it so
there's also so I was just asking
because we got $10 million from the
legislature that we ran you know uh an
award for and we award it 100% they're
not admin services keeps that on their
books and then they give us the money as
we draw down so it's almost like a G5
account with the Fed so I have $10
million that we've awarded as well off
outside of this and as we expend it then
we just draw down the funds from to
admin services to reimburse the
schools talking about this in Bud go
like best of viels with cameras lock
doors correct we do access controls
emergency alert in and emergency
response projects in guns it's is good
you know we want to do this this is
non-reactive nobody can just walk in
hopefully not like I I see these events
that happen in other schools and I just
say to myself how can that you know what
have we done that's going to make sure
that doesn't happen here walk in with a
gun on your on your back or in your
hands yeah rifle or they shoot their way
in or they throw a brick through the
window and break their way in all
different kinds of
things so
the balance in 2020
was didn't you say was it 10 million was
it shows a balance here of 12 million
544 um that had a beginning balance of
16 million yeah remember we started this
fund I don't I'm trying to remember when
we first started it might have been
before 2020 we started with that I think
Ken you might remember didn't we get
like 30 million I got I got 30 million
$29 million initially and then you guys
added some more funds to that adding it
almost every year and then every year
meon four allocations right and yeah I
use $10 million of eser funds as well in
this yeah yeah so it was you know it
make a big deal out and seemed like it
almost covered all the schools we we
awarded um so when we did the access
controls we opened up the Grant and 100%
of the access control applications got
funded
y so is there still a continuing need
after
this year there is I mean we have grants
out there that are live that are going
to extend another 18 months then we've
got a backlog of people so if funds get
returned to us then we regant those
funds to the schools on the backlog and
then I can tell you in my budget
submission I'm asking for additional
funding to continue this program
so we could call it instead a public
school infrastructure it's really now
public
safety fund
of a CH to school on
Saturday say that again I had a tour oh
you did which one C coast c Coast
Charter yeah
classic nice building yeah it's fairly
new I thought I thought it would be the
old middle school but it's it's a
totally different building yeah they're
in office space that they converted yeah
can Charter Schools apply for these
money they
can this one didn't seem to have access
to trolls oh they
didn't just remember going in the front
door he walked right in it's not good
yeah I'm sure I'll call
them kind of they haven't got on the
list yet they're not a school so they
can't apply yet so oh
okay all right mine's in charge of
school what's
that but it's in an old regular
school all right which is dead manur
Advanced manufacturing educ so you all
repealed this when we thought in July 23
July 2023 okay yeah all right so it
shouldn't be in the book anymore
shouldn't be yeah we take it out of the
book it never got off the ground I mean
it was I remember I think it was K
Williams who set it up with the idea of
trying to get companies to contribute to
it well yeah the idea was that that the
head of the um New Hampshire
Bank
uh Bank
Authority was supposed to go out was
either was faced with a choice of either
you bond this money for us $5
million with no security that they'd
ever get any money back to pay for the
bond or you go out and you find owners
so that New Hampshire would present
money to the dean Cayman operation so
that people around the country would
know that we were
engaged I was heavily involved in this
development okay not in the what how it
ended
but but Dean cayman's doing quite well
without
it so all right and the other one sign
language same thing
um it was just established in 2019 yeah
again with the idea of some funding
coming in but nothing's happened there
so
yeah um solot is hoping to he wants to
do something with it see so we have a
new director over vocation
Rehabilitation Tammy saying who thinks
he wants to try and go raise money but
right so far he hasn't raised any money
so no so you so you want to leave it for
one more
cyle yeah we have inactive list I'll
come to FAL if I need something it I
don't know yeah we don't even have an
accounting unit to so yeah
yeah well you how it is like you have a
new guy who comes in and says like I'll
use it and then
L like right
oh um and then there's one that's really
strange that doesn't have a 612 or
anything in the statutes
a reference to we're going to think
about
it which one is that the the current
ucation and training activities related
to Marine trade this is Senator Waters
and he was specifically focused around
the offshore wind yeah and thinking that
there would be a fee charged to those
offshore wind uh development projects
that would fund this but nothing has
happened yeah apparently in your report
you put it at the bottom and you said to
be determined by a
committee and the committee hasn't yet
been
created uh um it's a legislative
committee but again there's no offshore
wind so I don't think anybody decided
they need to get together yet so well
there is offshore wind but we aren't in
it okay well it's goingon to be hard to
fund this then it's going be to collect
fees from right all right so we can just
take that off of that yeah that
just remove that from the spreadsheet
and the report I
think Dan what
we oh rather than removing the committee
yeah but do we want to include
[Music]
the the cart which is actually remote
captioning I looked it up
mhm
so I have a sof spot my heart for
interpreters and remote captioners but
on this one
obviously isn't going anywhere but we're
just going to let it not go anywhere for
a few more
years
yeah the other one doesn't even have
that all right I've got a column called
review next year but we haven't been
doing that we review well we ask for the
list every year we only do this every
five years right and we do this every
five years so um the general thought was
to give them five years before we killed
them
but well this is five years
2019 it is you're right
yes yeah so well so here we are we could
we could try deleting it in what we put
into the committee and then see who
comes and starts saying complaints yeah
start saying oh but we're just about to
start a fundraising
yeah yeah I would say delet it
myself and see who s yeah that's right
so delete both of these so we only have
two three three was already R one's
already gone one's already see what else
which one is already gone this one the
last one but as was said I mean like the
vending we could do it through an
account we don't have to have a
dedicated fund Tammy's okay with that
bending um like know words I don't know
that I need a dedicated account for that
I just need an accounting unit collect
money in and push money out that is true
but it is revenue so if we have excess
Revenue at the end of the year I need
language in the law saying that it's
non-aps otherwise it would be La I
wouldn't have authority to keep that
revenue on the books it would laps to
the general fund well I mean the vending
I mean it seems like you're using it
yeah we are right but again if you
wanted to if your goal is to minimize
funds we could do that in other
accounting mechanisms is all I was
suggesting so yeah
I don't know that one seems to have a
weird purpose yeah it
is a a purpose for maybe eight
individuals or
something I it's a limited number of
individuals
um yeah right but they like but it's
their career right that's right what
they and when you go to get a Snickers
bar you're happy that they're doing it
right yeah
all right anything else for Department
of Education so you we have a couple of
little and school building authority I
think you said you were going to which
school building author building
authority yeah that would be and I'm
going to check on the
120% and you're going to call uh Kathy
preventure about Hattie and Harriet
exactly okay yeah and we'll and we'll
see about changing 2500 to 5,000
yeah okay so we have a few action items
yeah we do have some other actions out
here right
okay anything else for
today all right we're going to meet
Wednesday at 10
o'clock and thank you and at 1 yes so
we're adjourned yeah let me have five
minutes okay yeah and me too and I will
try to get the next annotated
spreadsheet
done no
Yeah by late Tu
Tuesday depends on how long we go in the
morning can't
go I
have e